UFC partners with Bud Lights as
embattled beer tries to fight off Dylan
mulany backlash I don't understand this
I'll break it
down I'll break it down very simply Bud
Light they're having a meeting being
like okay everybody's calling us names
and saying we're weak and effeminate and
gay and whatever we need to sponsor the
manliest thing imaginable how about MMA
they go to UFC I bet the first phone
call they had with UFC UFC is like are
you joking and wait wait wait wait don't
hang up don't hang up we'll give you
$100 million and they're like that's not
a lot of money to UFC
that bid starting bid I mean you're
right I'd like to see what the price tag
it's like UFC is owned by Endeavor right
so Endeavor is this massive conglomerate
that just bought WWE as well so they own
both of these companies it's all AR
manual it's a $100 million wouldn't even
move the needle for that and I just want
to say I know we were critiquing people
for not standing by their value at the
top of the show um I thought we were
trying to get rid of the fratty culture
around uh uh around you know let me read
this an Eiser Bush and budlight were
UFC's original beer sponsors more than
15 years ago I'm proud to announce we
are back in business together Dana White
said in the statement there are many
reasons why I chose to go with anheiser
bush and Bud Light most importantly
because I feel we are very aligned when
it comes to our core values and what the
UFC brand stands for I'm looking forward
to all of the incredible things we will
do in the years ahead what he's really
saying is bro the paycheck was huge you
would not believe all the zeros vers Fox
we'll go on this the values they share
are the amount of zeros on the back of
the check yes so many zeros you cannot
the values he's referring to our
monetary values
right I don't know this is a good
picture too where he's just like look
guys just had to say they had to make a
longer check there was so many zeros I
mean Bud light's going to do whatever
Dana White asks now right going to be
the card girl or whatever no there's no
way that they they repartner with Dylan
M but but I I I this is what did what
did budlight try to sponsor
Harley-Davidson it didn't work nothing
worked dude they really think I I got to
be honest I'm I'm willing to bet there's
a lot of MMA guys who are going to be
like f no yeah they're going to be this
is here's what I imagine you're going to
hear like press conferences with some
Fighters and they're going to rag on
budlight it's going to it's going to be
worse for bud by trying to do this for
whatever reason MMA guys tend to be
particularly based as it were or
redpilled have you seen the entrance
that Donald Trump made at the last UFC
fight in Las Vegas Dana White and Mark
walber both said they've never heard
anything like that do you think do you
think Donald Trump is GNA walk back down
hand inand with Dana White holding a
freaking Bud Light like you're right
those Fighters I know a lot of them I
live in Vegas my buddy has one of the
most successful MMA training centers and
owns like half the fighters in in the
UFC these guys are not going to tolerate
this and they have massive social media
following but it's not just about even
personal conviction if if you're someone
with a with a big presence and they're
they're telling you to stand in front of
a Bud Light you know Marquee or whatever
you're going to be like no I'm going to
get roasted are you nuts but then
they're going to say oh you're under
contract so you got to do it's going to
it's kind of it's going to get weird
yeah but MMA dudes are not the kind of
guys to like no a contractor the kind of
guy's going to be like I'll rip it up in
front of your face there's no second UFC
like they can't be like I'm switching
leagues and I'm going over here right
they they it's all owned by the one
thing there's there's there's the UFC
there's the pfl they're all owned by the
one look look there you you look at all
these industries we we're talking
earlier about like Jenna Alis pleading
guilty and they're all caving and
bending the knee UFC not even just just
MMA in general has a very high density
of individuals who will tell you to
shove it yeah but I think it's kind of
obvious like these are guys who work
really really hard they top athletes but
they're also very very capable people
who are not worried about what you think
you can take from them M yeah I'm
wondering how many MMA fighters go I
don't really care about that you
probably get some what's like the big
UFC chat space I would love to see what
they're posting already some of these
top fighters like if you look up the top
like 10 fighters to see if any one of
those guys have put something out on uh
on uh Dylan I can't believe this is a
headline what would their contracts look
like though like if you know if it
wasn't Bud life was a monster or
whatever like are they're not allowed to
disparage the brand like what what is it
there's usually non likee disparagement
Clauses or like you have to like wear
the shorts like are these guys going to
walk in with Bud Light on the floor of
the of the Octagon well it's a big
sponsorship also it's going to be such
terrible Optics like these guys
grappling on the ground over Bud Light
like I don't like it that's I mean just
picture these Optics like you have just
taken a monster defecation on Bud Light
for the last there is also there's a
large proponent of that industry that's
going to be very Normy that isn't going
to know what's going on with the
I think that's what they're betting I
think they're trying to see I think
there's plenty of nor I think that we
fall into a little bit of of tunnel
vision here I will say the budlight the
budlight and the target back-to-back
boycotts were so big I mean I know
non-political people who were really mad
about this and so they are gambling that
yeah both of them but the the thing is
they're gambling that these these issues
from earlier in the year have been
memory hold and I just don't think
that's the case I think especially with
the people in this particular industry
they remember they oppose it no and the
UFC World RIT large I mean you got to
you you're right I think in any other
sports it would be diluted but the UFC
world I mean you got to pull up the
video of trump all of those people went
eight1 million Stu eight no way that's
I'm pretty sure I mean well I'm I'm
looking at tweets they're all in on it
there was um people are tweeting $100
million maybe the most hilariously
dystopian thing I saw this year was
watching like during the playoffs for
baseball there's like a giant locky
Martin sign behind like in in center
field during the Astros uh it was just
yeah $100 million and how much stock
does Dana White personally own in in Bud
Light like if it goes back up what does
he get out of my understanding is that
if he bought stock in anheiser Bush
before this deal that's insider trading
but what if they gave it to him as part
of the deal right you know what I mean
so now yeah well actually no not him
individually so if it's $100 million
deal if they cut him in on the side I
think that's also insider trading yeah
I'm just wondering because like if that
does seem low hundred million dollars so
I have to assume that he is personally
profiting in some way like I I buy that
the people that are there live with the
event would would be that way they
ditched Modello yeah yeah they did we
like Modello yeah we
wow that's crazy we were like it's the
biggest sponsorship in UFC history
Target's the next one guys I tell you
like he said we share a lot of values
and that value is monetary yeah true I
mean Bellator is probably excited about
this they're definitely get some
Fighters going to be like ah screw this
I'm going to go to Bellator yeah yeah
honestly yeah so that's the thing if
they have an alternative you're
potentially losing good fighters to that
it just depends on how like that's why I
want to know about the contracts if they
can't get out of it they have to they're
all owned by the same Bellator UFC and
pfl are all the same but they're not
going to have to wear like the jerseys
of the shorts if they change you know
what I mean even if it's ultimately own
well who's going to be the first guy to
wear budlight
figh Bud Light shorts meme to to high
hell I can tell you that but I really
like you said it's the same owner go
they're just going to go to the other
the other bouts would they why would
they around if they're the only one
sponsoring bu light and let's say
Bellator isn't then why wouldn't they
just go fight Bellator yeah maybe the
pot the cat I guess Mone the money the
pot different yeah the cut is way less
but would it change if more people were
in the league yeah that's what I mean
what if all the viewers are like I'm not
going to watch UFC anymore because of
this forget this Trump fraud stuff tell
us about this guys you'd have to upend
like you'd have to get all the tier one
Fighters out of the UFC dump them down
into the pfl and Bellator where most of
the amateur fights are and you'd have to
reorient the I mean Dana White owns it
so well he own it but Dana runs it
they're not going to change what a
multi-billion dollar industry um I mean
maybe if this Bud Light thing backfires
but um 100 million just seems small I I
don't know why but it seems it seems
small to me for for that type of uh that
type of investment right so maybe they
really do share values and that's
terrifying right what values are we
getting from Bud Light right now man
timcast could have sponsored it for that
kind of money yeah no way you don't want
you don't want to have your face on all
of the UFC's uh jerseys and stuff yeah
if I had $100 million jeez know anybody
no I mean Bud Light if Bud Light Came to
Me and offered me $100 million I would
say no this is what I was talking about
earlier with like these corrupt people
in Congress that make all this money I'm
like I don't I don't I don't understand
it I mean at a certain point
like maybe it's just like a leftist
worldview I don't know at what point
does budlight try to get on Public
Square that's what I really want bl
light is like please Michael in five in
five years when Public Square is bigger
than Amazon and anyone who's not on that
platform is is struggling to get sales
because they're considered Fringe and
weird budlight then apologizes and
pledges to support American values and
family values and you could never trust
them you could never trust them to do
any of Tucker just putting a million on
Public Square a Public Square put a
million on Tucker yeah sorry I know it's
amazing it's a smart move a brilliant
move Tucker's got a massive show with a
massive presence and now Public Square
gets the sole sponsorship for a million
bucks it's a good deal for them it's a
great deal I mean Public Square is is
the most important uh uh culture War
business and application right now you
download an app that shows you the
businesses that agree with your values
that's it yeah no question it's
incredible and it was it it's so amazing
that Michael saw the need and filled it
I mean that's what I wish more people
they've had a rough ride though they
came in high and it's pretty down right
now in the in the stock world do you
thinking yeah they came in at like 30
they're at like 5 now Public Square is
well that's normal though like that's a
big drop from an IPO inside of a year
yeah but Facebook went from like what 45
to like 9 you're right it it's it that's
why everyone's always like be careful
when buying at an IPO because it always
drops off they sell they sell it they
dump a whole bunch and it falls down yep
yeah but you know it is what it is all
my concern
is is how are we winning the culture War
and what are we doing and we had we had
Carl Benjamin on the show and he was
like the right's not organized not doing
anything and then I'm like Public Square
does this and his eyebrows go up and
he's like oh that's actually brilliant
and right there are companies out there
they
it's hard to break through there's a lot
of companies that see this the world
that way there's cell phone companies
there's coffee companies there's payment
processing companies all these people do
it it's just it's a beast someone
already super chated saying they
canceled their UFC Fight Pass
subscription o it is also hard keep
tally going a lot of these like if a if
a larger company then offers you a ton
of money Jeremy's Fighting
Championships JFC JFC I got I'm I'm
going to text Jeremy boring right now
and be like bro can you launch an
MMA his brand is crazier and crazier and
they all have the chocolate bars with
them like I'm imagining like his
assistant runs into his office right now
and they're like they're like Mr boring
Mr boring and they hold up the paper and
he's
like wait so does this work or does this
not work he's like who here is in the
best shape we need to film an ad right
now yeah what do you think does this
take for UFC does this work or does this
not oh no I think they're I think
they're gonna eat it well look no matter
what happens there is going to be
controversy the fact that we're even
talking about it and people are saying
they're cancelling because of it there's
already controversy it may not be that
big of a deal because the average person
who watches MMA or whatever might just
be like dude I don't care about that
stuff I want to watch the the champion
fight the champ fight the the you know
the the contender or whatever and so
we'll see but I I kind of think a lot of
UFC guys are very vocal politically they
don't care like they they believe what
they believe and they are not weak
people like it is a high density of
individuals that are in MMA that are
just like I will say what I believe
screw you I don't think it'll be the
boycott that we saw with budlight itself
because Bud Light you can pick
Alternatives right if there's really no
alternative you see there are people who
are like look I like this I work hard I
want to watch the fights like I'm not
going to buy are they going to have
other beers there I don't know so so
when this was going down I went to I I
spent a lot of time in Nashville and and
I'm a big country music fan and I went
to uh a Luke Holmes concert out in in
Titan Stadium like you know 55,000
people and they were still under
contract with Bud Light whoever was
putting on that that show when I left
the
arena I couldn't find when I walked in I
couldn't find one person holding a can
of Bud Light they were drinking
everything else that they could get
their hands on when I left the arena
there were truckloads of Bud Light
stations around the arena that had not
sold like more than 3% of their beers I
mean they were just stacked to the
ceiling so if they did that in country
music in Nashville like it's not a far
stretch that they don't buy their stuff
here now I guess it doesn't
matter what happens if a fighter comes
out and and right when he comes he goes
don't buy Bud Light somebody's gonna say
that somebody some dude is getting up
and saying that and and Bud light's
goingon to be like wow this made things
worth actually made it worse there's a
massive fight in Madison Square Garden
in two weeks UFC is going there and um
supposedly there's going to be some
appearances from some celebrities like
Dylan mulany oh interesting so we'll see
how this sh we're going to know how this
shakes out I'm telling you in like two
weeks it's just they they Bud Light has
had a marketing catastrophe since this
started and they've never figured out
what to do about it because they could
have just apologized yeah we got it
wrong see you later sorry guys we this
was an you know a young marketing
Millennial we we we we apologize we're
not going to do it again instead they've
been double they've beening triple
quadruple down oh they've been
sponsoring Pride events but then all of
what was this the gay bars in Chicago
were like we're not buying that beer
you're not supporting Dylan malany
enough yep they got double out that's
right and all of the leftists who
weren't buying it anyways are just going
to not buy it anyways because they
weren't buying it in the first place it
it was a dumb move and like I said they
their their marketing executive said
that thing I came in to to fix the
fratty reputation I'm sorry but I
learned about UFC with guys who were in
fraternities that they were the ones who
were playing it every Saturday do you
think that this is football like that's
this has become every marketing
department in a lot of American
companies now is they're chasing this
Phantom audience that they believe that
they can expand their portfolio on right
they think that there's this magical
group it's happened in comics it's
happened in films and they always think
there's this magical group of people
first of all they don't have money the
people that they're actually looking to
buy stuff for they're not they don't
have money anyways and they go looking
for it and then they end up destroying
their own market share by insulting the
people that they actually make the
profit uh make it for in the first place
but then these these guys come in on the
other side I don't know if you saw I
can't remember the name of company it's
like conservative beer of America or
whatever Ultra right Ultra
righted Ultra R like now it's like $2
million or something yeah well that's
why I said Jeremy's Fighting
Championship or whatever whatever youc
stands for uh Jeremy boring got a
chocolate bar company we got to order
more of those by the way everybody
really loved them but people didn't like
the one with nuts they like the ones
with no nuts cuz it's it's he him she I
want her to make a dark dark chocolate
bar that's what I'm waiting for I'm sure
that name won't be
at all I'd love to see what he comes up
with it'll be fantastic let's just let's
just find out it is always funny though
every time a new product has to come out
it's like Patriot water and some and
some new product stars and strip cereal
remember uh hey that's not a bad ideaal
anyone makes that I think it was Ryan
long who did that video where it's like
leftwing podcast sponsors versus
rightwing patri dirt the leftwing one
was like we're you know welcome to the
anti-establishment anti you know
anti-government podcast sponsored by
Monsanto and then right yeah and on the
right it was like Patriot water it's
water but for Patriots and he's like and
the other ones it was all MREs and yeah
and uh in instant food leftwing podcasts
all have massive sponsors from McDonald
yeah yeah big corporations Ryan long
doesn't miss oh yeah no he had that
really good one about Israel Palestine
that was that was brilliant actor
doesn't know who to support and they
were another one that of his that's been
going around again recently is the
winner he's like I sell my I sell the
footage to Fox and I sell the footage to
CNN M you play it backwards it looks
fine no no he's like I once sent p a
video to Fox News of protesters picking
up litter and I said don't worry if you
play it backwards they're they're
littering maybe this is who the dis
campaign needs right they need Ryan long
to come in and be like this is how you
respond to Ashley St Clair's boot thing
they need a Canadian come in and fix it
they need some foreign Nationals
Consulting this is this is the point I
made about Trump is that here's that one
clip where he's like the lights they're
too bright they're making me look orange
and everyone busts out laughing you
can't make fun of trump because Trump in
on the joke desantis's campaign doesn't
get that or they're intentionally
sabotaging him so they're just like
don't make fun of me you're stupid
you're dumb it's like wow that was none
of it's Landing none of it's sticking
it's just his campaign's over I mean I
think so yeah I don't know but I will
watch that debate between him and N
maybe Bud Light can sponsor that debate
yeah I'm more interested in whether or
not a UFC fighter comes out and says yo
what I want to fight you know what let
me text a few right now yeah would like
some exclusive comments from them on air
that'd be great yeah I mean my my
question again goes back to contracts
like what are they allowed to say and I
would be interested if if in violation
of their contract potentially giving up
a lot of money they say something
anyways because I think that is what we
need people who are saying I don't like
this and I didn't forget why we were
boycotting Bud Light in the first place
I still remember why we were not buying
things at Target I mean that's the the
fact of boycott they it's difficult for
them to last forever especially if
there's no alternative on the other hand
let's not for forget why we went into
them in the first place it it it was
earlier this year we can't have seated
the ground so quickly is that a big part
of it though did is is in Dana White's
mind is the idea that they they waited
like a a sufficient amount of time has
passed and and trying it now is not the
same as trying it in August or trying it
in sep sure I mean I don't think you
would have touched it in July right but
on the other hand uh I it makes me
wonder what the money and it makes me
wonder about his potential other
dealings I think it does not go well
yeah there's no way right this is gon to
this is not I can't wait now to get back
home and be like WTF what are you and
all of these Fighters that you know can
be like Bud Light really gross yeah they
already hated it yeah so now are they
going to be forced to paint it on their
face like where they walk out yeah Bud
Light Flags blood light cups they're
gonna it's it we'll know couple weeks
huge fight Madison Square Garden mhm
that's crazy yeah we see Strickland and
Covington and all those was have to say
about it too CU they've been pretty
pretty outright about their opinions so
they're not as Tim said they ain't
shutting up no definitely not I mean
unless they are made to shut up that's
that's what I come back to there are
always obligations where I mean yeah but
like these guys are just they don't even
they don't they don't care about the
contract here let's see what this UFC
fighter said oh my God breaking news
live on
10 does he know you're on air right now
are we allowed to say who it is uh oh no
I'm not going to say who it is but uh
what what the heck I just said we were
having breaking news what did they say
the fighters don't know about it and
they're pissed so they found out with
everyone else they are the Sophie Turner
Jo it's kind of like yeah how apparently
all big news breaks nowadays you don't
tell your own people you just tell the
this came out uh a couple hours ago this
news broke and wow it's a Tuesday
evening is like the the best possible
day for Bud Light it's maximum PR day
Tuesday Friday and Saturday Saturday is
like just things get lost un unheard of
to release something on Saturday Friday
5 Friday at 5 is where you bury it but
they like Bud Light was like and we want
you to announce Tuesday evening this is
a great in the middle of a war in the
middle of you know he's like could we
soften it to Thursday at 10: they were
confident it was a Tuesday I just can't
imagine though can you imagine like this
is a great idea Dana White says yes and
everyone will not will not think about
it well they're they're just going to
see the power of USC probably fade Just
a Touch here on this one because they
might have the Golden Touch but not not
the budlike Golden Touch it ain't coming
back I'm sorry it's a tall I mean and
the thing about the Bud Light boycotts
is there are tons of people who work you
know in their breweries or whatever else
who are normal people who were swept up
in a national controversy that I'm sure
they didn't actually want to be a part
of right I mean this is Corporate
leadership betraying the actual workers
like maybe budle can sponsor
Hamas so so you know I I'll read I'll
read the super chats more in detail but
uh I'll just uh paraphrase one saying
that you know a lot of these Fighters
don't make a lot of money yeah Dana
White bringing bringing in this money
could help get these guys paid more and
I'm just like look if you're if you're
Pro doesn't make it to them if you've
got sponsors let's say you've got five
sponsors you've got companies a b c d
and e and then you decide to add on Bud
Light and now you have a big Bud Light
patch on your on your your jacket or
your pants or whatever those other
companies are going to be like dude dude
dude dude dude out we're done we're
we're cutting you off I mean look if if
like we sponsored something and then
someone decided to put Bud Light next to
it I'd be like no way dude like we don't
want to be associated with that we're
not going to sponsor if you're working
with with with them because it's just
like we don't agree with their values
it's bad across the
board that's a problem I'm wondering I
don't know how sponsorships works for
work for a lot of these Fighters but
sponsorships are a big portion of how
athletes make money I assume it's the
same for UFC if if if they're now like
look man we don't we don't want to be
overlapping with Bud Light our audience
like let's say there's a jerky company
they're going to be like if people find
out that we're sponsoring this stuff
like we're going to lose money we just
we're better off sponsoring something
else no it's like 100 100 to 200,000 a
patch right on a short or something like
that and you have like two two maybe
three right so yeah are you going to
pull those off to put budlight on and
what is budlight going to offer you or
is the UFC going to mandate that if you
want to fight in the UFC you have to
have the Bud Light logo on your on your
stuff in in and that would force it and
then I don't think it's likely but there
is a pro a slim probability that there's
a massive backlash to UFC over doing
this Bud Light thing like you're
mentioning Fighters are pissed I don't
know to what degree people actually care
but let's just oper assumption there's a
a big backlash I mean the people
screaming cheering for Trump are going
to be like boo it's going to be gnarly
and then if that does happen you will
get other sponsors going to UFC and
being like do not put our logo next to
Bud Light y we like we we do not want to
be a part of whatever it is you're a
part of you do that that's fine is Dana
White risking losing other sponsors by
doing this deal with Bud Light I I I
think so I mean I just don't see how the
Loyalty brand that UFC has built up and
whether or not you think UFC's political
you have to just go to one of these
events and look at the people and talk
to them they are dialed in they are
educated they are more into the know
about the news and mainstream media than
people give them credit for because
they're like oh you guys just like
fights they're actually more dialed in
than anything else you can't get that
kind of reaction to anyone walking in
unless they know what the F's going on
and and they side with them like it's
not like they hate them in unison they
went the other way so if you fill a
stadium full of people with like that
for your sport I can't imagine the other
people watching it aren't feeling mostly
the same way in some form and especially
the the social media responses I saw
were for people who weren't there were
exactly the same way someone uh in the
regular chat said everyone has a price
Million Dollar Man even your mothers
have a price and that's just not true it
is not true that everyone has a price
most do most do um and that price could
actually be lower than people realize or
higher than people realize and uh I
wonder if that's just people have not
tried to sign deals before like there
are people with no price none and as
we've tried to hire and acquire you
learn 90 plus per of people in the space
there is no price you could buy them for
90 plus and I'm not talking about
compromising vales I'm talking about
we've gone to people who have like
moderate social media followings and
we're like would you want to like join
the timcast team and like we would help
distribute and Market and they're like
no why I don't need it what am I going
to do with it and I'm like well like we
could we could help you make more money
we'll pay you more up front we'll then
seek ways to monetize we'll then try and
like we we'll we'll promote it and
they're like no thanks thoughh there
it's just like it's not hostile they
just don't need it right it's for a lot
of these people with social media and
the internet when they're making six
figures on their own already there is
nothing you can offer them because
they're like Freedom it's like I could
take a day off whenever I want I answer
to no one I've got good money for what
reason what I signed this deal and I'm
like you're right fa and for most people
deals offer security but if they feel
confident they're if they're established
enough like they don't they don't need
that either it's like being a small
business the challenge is most people
worth hiring are people who have proven
with a portfolio of their work and have
already found ways of monetizing it in
the modern era so I I I I you know it's
not just that too but especially in the
world of political convictions you'll
find a lot of people are just unwilling
to do deals hey Bud Light had a price I
mean UFC had a price yeah
I'm really interested like all the MMA
fighters coming out being like no and
which one of them's going to be like 100
million are you kidding me we we could
have gone for more yeah oh for real they
could have gone for more I bet I bet if
they went to Bud Light and says this is
your only chance you got to you got to
make it a billion dollars some
ridiculous number a billion over should
have I don't know what they were
thinking over the course over a period
of time the way they would do it is like
a billion dollars over 10 years or
whatever I mean maybe it's $100 million
for the 10 I like is there a way de
brand and and the1 you're seeing isn't
confirmed by the brands it's just
something you're seeing report online
right a bunch of news outlets have
reported $100 million yeah thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net